ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สายสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนถูกต้องค่ะก็
กลับพบกับครูฟ้าและผู้หญิง
คือครูฟ้าและครูหญิงนะคะในดีจีนเอ้อเอ้อ
Class ใช่แล้วน้องวีดีโอบีกินเนอร์นะคะ
ครูฟ้าขาวันนี้วันอะไร
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะวันนี้วันจันทร์วันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันจันทร์ที่ 22
เดือนอะไร
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนค่ะเดือนพฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่
เท่าไหร่คะอ่ะก็คือสติกายนต์เป็นเดือนที่
11 หักปีพตต
ปีพ.ศ
2556  4 ปีคศ
2  021
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันอาทิตย์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันอาทิตย์ที่ 21
ค่ะเดือน
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็น
เดือนที่ 11 นะค่ะปีพต
2564 ขยับมานี่ไม่เห็นไม่เห็นจะปีคศ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะธเตือนพรุ่งนี้อยู่วัน
อังคารค่ะวันอังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 23 ค่ะเดือน
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็น
เดือนที่ 11 ค่ะปีพตตปีพศ 2564 ค่ะปีคศ 2
021 ค่ะวันนี้ก็เป็นวันจันทร์เย้เฮเวลา
ล่ะแล้วตอนนี้ใช่ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วครู
ฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
11:00 น 11 โมงกี่นาทีคะ
11:07 ค่ะ 11 โมงกะหรี่ 11:07 แล้ว
หนูเลย
คุณครูหญิงสบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะครูฟ้าล่ะ
คะ
ครูฟ้าสบายดีค่ะ
ดีค่ะเพราะว่าครูหญิงมีคำถามอีกแล้ว
คำถามคำถามสถามครูฟ้า
ถามอะไรคะเราจะถามเกี่ยวกับ
หนี้ค่า
ทำงานใช่ไหมกูฟ้าที่เป็นนักร้องเป็นทหาร
หมอ
ตำรวจพยาบาลมันก็เลยมีคำถามสถามครูฟ้า
อยากรู้สายถักทางเฟส
อันนี้อาชีพอะไรคะคือฟ้า
อันนี้อาชีพ
แก้ปวดค่ะหน้าตามรูปครูฟ้าอยากเป็นอยาก
เป็นตำรวจไหน
รูปฟ้า
อยากเป็นตำรวจไหม
ตอนเด็กๆ
ตาต่ออายุ
อายุเท่าไหร่คะ
อายุ 8 ขวบ
ครูฟ้าอายุ 8 ขวบอยากเป็นตำรวจขาวหูฝาก็
วันนี้ครูฟ้าใช่ไหม
ครูป๊าป๊า
ก็คิดคิดๆใช่ไหมหูฟ้าคิดอยากเป็นตำรวจยาก
เป็นตำรวจครู
คิดถึงนะคะครูหญิงอยากเป็นตำรวจไหมคะผู้
หญิงไม่อยากเป็นตำรวจค่ะใช่เอาแต่ไม่ชอบ
ครูฟ้าอยากเป็นตำรวจ
อ่ะปาชีพต่อไปค่ะคุณฟ้าอะไรคะทหารค่ะทหาร
ครูฟ้าอยากเป็นทหารไหม
ครูฟ้า
ไม่อยากเป็นทหารค่ะเอา
ไม่อยากเป็นทหาร
ผู้หญิงอยากเป็นทหารไหมคะครูหญิงไม่อยาก
เป็นทหารค่ะ
เหมือนครูฟ้า
ต่อไปอาชีพอะไรคะถูกฟ้าผ่าหมอหมอหมอ
ครูฟ้าอยากเป็นหมอไหม
ครูฟ้าอ่ะไม่อยากเป็นหมอค่ะ
ไม่อยากเป็นหมอแต่ชอบดูซีรี่ย์หมอนะหมอ
บอกแต่ไม่อยากเป็นแฟนหนูผู้หญิงอยากเป็น
หมอไหมคะผู้หญิงไม่อยากเป็นหมอค่ะ
หนูเหมือนครูฟ้าอีกแล้วไม่อยากเป็นหมอ
มาดูอาชีพต่อไปอาชีพอะไรคะ
พยาบาล
พยาบาลครูฟ้าอยากเป็นพยาบาลไหม
ครูฟ้าไม่อยากเป็นพยาบาลค่ะ
ไม่อยากเป็นพยาบาลเหรอท่าน
ผู้หญิงอยากเป็นพยาบาลไหมคะครูหญิงไม่
อยากเป็นพยาบาลค่ะ
ไม่อยากจะอยากเป็นอ่ะต่อไปค่ะอาชีพอะไรคะ
คุณครูค่ะยิ่งคุณครูครูฟ้าอยากเป็นครูไหม
คะ
ครูฟ้า
ไม่อยากเป็นคนครูค่ะไม่อยากเป็นครูครูว่า
เนาะแบบชดเลยไม่กลับเป็นครูค่ะเอ้าแต่
เป็นครู
แต่ครูฟ้าเป็นครูแต่ไม่อยากเป็นครูในไทย
ครู
ไม่อยากเป็นผู้หญิงอยากเป็นครูไหมคะครู
หญิงอยากเป็นครูค่ะอ่ะถ้าอยากเป็นครูฟ้า
ไม่อยากเป็นครูครูหญิงอยากเป็นครูอันนี้
ไม่เหมือนกัน
อ่ะต่อไปค่ะอาชีพอะไรคะ
นักบินค่ะนัดบินครูฟ้าอยากเป็นนักบินไหม
ครูฟ้า
ไม่อยากเป็นนักบินค่ะ
ไม่อยากเป็นนักบินผู้หญิงอยากเป็นนักบิน
ไหมคะครูหญิง
อยากเป็นนักบินค่ะมากมายอยากจะ
ไม่เอา
หนือนครูฟ้าครับ
อ่ะต่อไปอาชีพอะไรคะครูฟ้าอ่ะ
คุณแม่ครัว
แม่ครัวครูฟ้าอยากเป็นแม่ครัวไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าไม่อยากเป็นแมครัวพออ๋อนะ
ครัวอ้าว
เปลี่ยนใจหรอคะคิดคิดๆอยากเป็นหรือว่าไม่
อยากเป็นถ้าเป็นแม่ครัวทำเบเกอร์รี่
beckley เนาะแบบนี้
ใช่ Bakery แบบนิดลูกค้าอยากเป็นค่ะต่อ
ถ้าเป็นแม่ครัวหรือว่าเชฟใช่มั้ยไม่อยาก
เป็น
โอเคงั้นครูฟ้าอยากเป็นคนทำเบเกอร์รี่
สมัยจากเต้นอยากกินให้เด็กที่ผู้หญิงอยาก
เป็นแม่น่ากลัวไหมคะไม่อยากเป็นค่ะปุ๋ย
ไม่เอาแม่อยากเป็นแม่ครัวคนทำเบเกอร์รี่
ก็ไม่อยากเป็น
วุ้น
มายากเลยไปเลยอ่ะต่อไปค่ะอาชีพอะไรคะครู
ฟ้า
ช่างช่างภาพไหมช่างภาพครูฟ้าอยากเป็นช่าง
ภาพไหม
ครูฟ้า
เงิน
ไม่อยากเป็นช่างภาพงูไม่อยากไปนิดแต่ผู้
ฟ้าชอบถ่ายรูปแบบนี้จะแวะนี้ผู้ชายคนนี้
เนี่ยเขากำลังถ่ายรูปไปก็เป็นช่างภาพใน
ถ่ายรูปถ่ายรูปในโทรศัพท์ใช่ไหมอ่ะอย่า
เพิ่งรู้ถ่ายรูปลูกค้าโอเคชอบถ่ายรูปแต่
จริงๆแต่ไม่อยากเป็นช่างภาพค่ะผู้หญิง
อยากเป็นช่างภาพไหมคะครูหญิง
อย่าเป็นช่างภาพค่ะ
ถ่ายรูปใช่ไหมทางๆเนี่ยถ่ายรูปถ่ายรูป
ชาติผู้หญิงผู้หญิงชอบถ่ายรูปหรือก็เลย
คิดๆอยากเป็นช่างผ้าสมัยช่างภาพเนี่ยถ่าย
รูปเก่งเลข 5
อยากเป็นช่างค่า
ได้อ่ะต่อไปอาชีพอะไรคะครูป๊า
นักบินอวกาศนะคะเตือนฉันนะนักบินอวกาศครู
ฟ้าอยากเป็นนักบินอวกาศไหม
รูปฟ้าอยากเป็นนักบินอวกาศค่ะโอ้ยอยาก
เป็นอยากเป็นนักบินอวกาศผู้ฟ้าเนี่ยอยาก
ไปนาซ่าผมไม่ถ้าเป็นนักบินอวกาศสมัยครู
ฟ้าก็จะได้ไป
ดวงจันทร์สถานใจดวงจันทร์
เขา
ตาดีอ่าผู้หญิงอยากเป็นนักบินอวกาศไหมคะ
ผู้หญิงก็จะเป็นนักบินอวกาศข้า
อยากเห็น
ดวงจันทร์อยากผู้หญิงใช่มั้ยคุณครู
ก็อยากไปดวงจังอืม
ดีว่าเป็นอีทีก็เลยคิดถึง Go  Home ใหญ่
อยากเป็นนักบินอวกาศนอก
ต่อไปสัตว์อาชีพอะไรคะครูฟ้า
นักดนตรีค่ะนักดนตรีครูฟ้าอยากเป็นนัก
ดนตรีไหม
ครูไฟล์อยากเป็นนักดนตรีค่ะ
อย่างไรรูปเนี่ยผู้ชายเป่า
แซกโซโฟนในดนตรีเนี่ยเป็น saxophone แล้ว
ครูฟ้าอยากเป็นนักดนตรีอะไรแจ็คโซโฟน
Guitar  Piano  Violin
ฟ้าอยากเป็น
นักดนตรีกีต้าหนอดี
หรือฟ้าแล้วก็มีกีตาร์
[เพลง]
เรียนจริงต้าค่ะ
นั่นแหละๆอยากเป็นนักดนตรีกีตาร์อย่า
เปลี่ยนกีต้าร์นะคะค่ะครูหญิงอยากเป็นนัก
ดนตรีไหมคะผู้หญิงไม่อยากเป็นนักดนตรี
ทั้งไม่เอา
แม่หญิงไม่เก่งไงก็ไม่อยากเป็นนักดนตรี
อยากครูบาอยากเป็นใช่ไหมชายประหยัดบิน
ดนตรีอ่ะต่อไปค่ะอาชีพอะไรคะลูกค้า
ชาวนาค่ะสาวนา
ครูฟ้าอยากเป็นชาวนาไหม
ครูฝาไม่อยากเป็นชาวนาค่ะมั้ยอยากด่า
หน้า
ร้อนไหม
เฉลยไม่อยากเป็นชาวนาผู้หญิงอยากเป็นชาว
นาไหมคะผู้หญิงก็ไม่อยากเป็นชาวนากันร้อน
นะร้อนก็เลยไม่อยากเป็นเอานาค่ะ
แล้ว
ทรูฟ้าอาชีพอะไรคะ
ช่าง
ภาพช่างตัดผมอ่ะช่างตัดผมหรือว่าช่างทำผม
สวยคนนี้คนนี้เป็นช่างนานก็ทำผมครูฟ้า
อยากเป็นช่างทำผมไหม
ครูฟ้า
คือ
คิดๆอยากเป็นอยากเป็นอยากเป็นอยากเป็นชู้
คะห๊า
ไม่อยากเป็นช่างทำบุ๋งค่ะโอเคกุ้งฝาคิด
แล้วไม่อยากเป็นช่างทำผมให้เพราะว่าผม
ภูฟ้าไม่โอเคเห็นมั้ยปาสตัดผมแล้วผมก็
ไปโอเคไม่โอเครู้หญิงอยากเป็นช่างทำผมไหม
คะอยากเป็น
อยากตั้งทำผมชอบจับผมใช้จับผมคิดต้องก็
เลยคิดอยากเป็นช่างทำผมโง่ดีว่าเก่งแต่
ครูซ้าอาชีพอะไรคะ
นักมายากลค่ะนักมายากลครูฟ้าอยากเป็นนัก
มายากลไหมครู
ลูกค้า
อยากเป็นนักมายากลค่ะ
สายอยากเป็นใช่มั้ยเปิดนี่ไหม
เมจิกไคโตะหาใครมาเหมือนการ์ตูนคอมมิคตูน
อ่านไปหานักพญากลครูหญิงอยากเป็นนักมายา
กลในอ่าผู้หญิงไม่อยากเป็นนกไม่อยากเป็น
นักมายากลป่ะไม่เอาไม่อยากเป็นไม่ชอบนั่ง
อ่ะสุดท้าย
อาชีพอะไรคะครูฟ้า
Designer หรอๆดีไซน์เนอะหรือว่าครูฟ้า
อยากเป็นดีไซเนอร์ไหม
ครูบาอาอยากเป็นดีไซเนอร์ค่ะ
ตัดเสื้อผ้าใช้ชุด Race บ่หัวซาช่างตัด
เสื้อผ้าดีไซเนอร์
แต่ว่าครูฟ้าขอ
แฟชั่นไอหายชอบดีไซน์เออ
ผู้หญิงอยากเป็นดีไซเนอร์ไม่คะผู้หญิงไม่
อยากเป็นค่ะไม่อยากเป็นดีไซเนอร์
ไม่อยากเป็นเนาะอ่ะมาดูว่าครูฟ้าอยากเป็น
อะไรบ้างได้ค่ะครูฟ้าอยากเป็นตำรวจแต่กู
ว่าอยากตำรวจ
อยากเป็นอะไรนะแม่ครัวทำขนมปังหรือว่ามี
เกอรี่น้องอันนี้คือขนมปัง
ขนมครูฟ้าอยากเป็นนักดนตรี
นักดนตรีเล่นกีต้าร์เล่นกีตาร์บาทครูฟ้า
อยากขอเป็นนัดมายากล
นักมายากลตัดแล้วก็ครูฟ้าอยากเป็น
ดีไซเนอร์นักดีไซน์เนอะ
ผู้หญิงสมัยครูหญิงอยากเป็นอยากเป็นอะไร
คะกริ๊งอยากเป็นครู
ฉะนั้นครู
หนิงอยากเป็นช่างภาพหรอ
แล้วก็ครูหญิงอยากเป็นช่างทำผม
นั่นทำโผแน่ๆแล้วก็ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าอยาก
เป็นนักบินอวกาศ
นักบินอวกาศตอนเหมือนกันสมัยแล้วก็ผู้
หญิงกับครูฟ้าไม่อยากเป็นชาวนา
ไม่อยากเป็นนักบิน
แต่บินไม่อยากเป็นพยาบาล
ไม่อยากเป็นหมอ
แล้วก็ไม่อยากเป็นทหารขาๆเกาะนักเรียน
อยากเป็นอะไร
คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้น้องไอ้วีดีโอนี้เรา
สองคนก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะไอ้ก่อนใช่แล้วอย่า
ลืมกดไลค์กดแชร์ด้วยนะเนาะแล้วเจอกัน
วีดีโอหน้าบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ
ยาค่ะ